sequential decision making which Matt
Weinberg is going to address and his
talks in the afternoon are going to be
talks today tomorrow SE hour we'll talk
about uh online algorithms and then uh
nikel bunel and Adam wman will talk
about connections between online
algorithms and queuing model stochastic
schedule models on Wednesday uh there'll
be three talks actually on the general
umbrella of machine
learning uh uh first off will be by
Ellie ukfall on uh sampling uh
approaches uh the second talk by Nicolo
chabani on online learning and the third
one by isai mansur on reinforcement
learning approaches and Thursday we'll
talk about something a little different
but very intimately connected with uh
the program uh the question of how do
you uh analyze algorithms beyond the
worst case and uh a lot of the
stochastic models are somehow lying
between the average in the worst case
and uh here there'll be two talks the
first talk in the morning by Tim R
garden and the second in the afternoon
by Kevin Leon Brown uh given giving like
complimentary ways of viewing uh the the
uh area and finally we we'll talk about
some applications and these are just two
of the applications which might arise uh
the first first talk will be by uh Anna
Carin on algorithmic mechanism design um
and the second one by and Ian on
applications of stochastic optimization
and in general algorithms under
uncertainty to energy problems so that's
the general framework uh and you know
each of these talks can be viewed by
itself it can be view you know it should
be viewed as part of a whole and it
should be viewed as a ways of either
reminding yourself of what you already
know learning something new Making
Connections you know hope you have good
time so that's pretty much it from me
Stefano has a couple of words to say
just quick information on the addal
information on the boot camp and the
organization of the program so the boot
camp will also have three uh sessions of
lightning talks these are short 5 minute
talks that allow the program
participants to present themselves and
to highlight the research directions of
protction so if you like to give a
lightning thought please send me email
by today then uh for the activities of
the program of course we plan several
activities we plan uh uh seminars we
plan open problem section sessions we
plan uh additional activities we'll also
encourage you to uh send us ideas for
reading groups or on more
specialized that you like to discuss to
learn about so if you like to propose
aing group please contact us
and we'll have an organizing meeting
organizing meeting next
Wednesday discuss activities that we
like to carry on in this so thank you
very much again and I guess I can give
the
floor okay so the first uh talk in the
session is going to be by Kam on
stochastic
uh thanks uh vishi and thanks uh anupam
and Stefano for inviting me here um so
uh uh the the topic of this tutorial is
stochastic optimization
um different people mean different
things when they say stochastic
optimization and uh for the purpose of
this talk it's good to think about
stochastic optimization as essentially
you want to design an algorithm but your
inputs instead of being detered
humanistic numbers are
distributions um so just to give some
context um there is this uh broad area
of research called Markov decision
processes uh in a typical Mark of
decision process you are given some set
s of States some set a of
actions and uh
so if you take if you're in some if the
there's a system and if the system is in
the state s and if it it has a choice of
actions to take if it takes action a uh
then it uh earns some reward let's
denote that ra of s it's drawn from some
distribution the distribution is known
uh to the decision maker and the system
transitions to a different state q and
the it could transition to one of
several States the probability with
which it transitions to state q is given
by this quantity which is indexed by the
action the previous state and the next
state so it's in this state you take an
action a it transitions
probabilistically to a different state
and it yields some reward drawn from a
distribution uh so what is the what is
the input to such a problem you're given
the states you're given the actions um
and you're given the reward distribution
for each state you're given these State
transition matrices what are the
probability for every state for every
action and every next state what is the
probability that you will transition to
that next state um you're given some
start state of the system s you're given
some time Horizon T so you can make a
sequence of T
actions and what you want to do is
maximize the expected reward that you
get over these T steps right and the
expectation is over uh the rewards
themselves are stochastic in every state
if you take an action the reward is
drawn from a distribution so there's
some expectation there and also the what
state you transition to is also
stochastic so the expectation is over
all this stuff right and so what is what
do you want to design right you want to
design what is called a decision policy
which is a mapping
from states to action if I am in this
state what action should I take
uh and this is sort of ancient it is 60
years old uh it is well known that in
fact the whole area of dynamic
programming was invented in this context
U by belman and so the optimal policy
can be computed is can be computed by
dynamic programming um it takes time
which is polinomial in the number of
states the number of actions and this
time Horizon uh the reason I'm being
brief here is that I'm not going to
focus on dynamic programming in this
talk
so in this talk what we want to focus on
is there are several problems and I'll
give you many examples of this where
either the number of states is
exponentially large in the natural
problem parameters or even if the number
of states is small the number of actions
is can be exponentially large right and
in this case if you do dynamic
programming it'll take exponential
time uh so the question is for these for
such kind of problems can we design are
there can we design decision policies
that are simple so they may not be
optimal but can we can can we show they
are approximately optimal um and they
should be efficient to it should be
efficient to find this policy and it
should also be efficient to execute this
policy so this is I'm keeping it high
level for now I'll give you very
concrete examples as the talk goes on um
if at any point you have questions
please feel free to
interrupt
okay so there
many this field of stochastic
optimization there there are lot of
problems that that people have looked at
that fall under this umbrella they are
if you can take any standard covering or
ordering problem and Define a stochastic
version of it I mean so there stochastic
set cover the variants of stochastic set
cover then there you can take any
scheduling problem and Define a
stochastic version of it where the input
instead of the job length of the job
being a fixed number it's a distribution
hey you have a stochastic version you
can have stochastic naps I mean take
take any sort of traditional
optimization problem I I'll show you a
stochastic version of it right and
another Well studied area and there'll
be talks on this later on is uh auctions
and even we can View Auction design as a
stochastic optimization problem so given
that this is like this big laundry list
I I don't want to give you I don't want
the stock to become a laundry list so
that's why what I'll do is I'll show
like a like one overall technique um or
a class of techniques that fall under
the framework of you want
to that you want to design linear
programming relaxations for these
problems and design rounding algorithms
for them right so these things are well
known for uh standard approximation
algorithms when you're inputs are
deterministic U Can we develop such
techniques when uh the inputs instead of
being deterministic numbers are
distributions okay
um so and that way the talk will become
more
coherent
so I'll divide the talk into four parts
the first part will take up this hour
and the second uh and the second third
and fourth part will take up the next
hour so in the first part I'll focus on
an extremely simple decision problem
I'll call it the maximum value problem
um and using this I'll illustrate the
basic concept I mean what is a policy
what is a decision tree um what is an
Adaptive policy non-adaptive policy I
mean I I I sort of describe these terms
in the context of this very simple
problem uh and we'll show how to design
non-adaptive policies I mean this this
is just a term for now um and then I'll
show you how to use LP
relaxations how these LP relaxations can
be rounded and what is the role of
Duality I mean whenever you have an LP
you can take its dual and get something
from the Dual and in the in this in
stochastic optimization often the duels
are extremely
nice uh that will be the first part of
the talk it'll take up this hour
and the the first part will be more like
a classroom so in the end you would have
learned at least learned
something so this in the second hour
I'll do part 2 3 4 here I'll sort of
have to define the problem and present
the high level algorithm but I won't
have time to go into any proofs and so
on so the second part I I sort of
generalize what I did in the first part
to what are called weekly coupled LPS so
which is basically a general technique
for using for developing these LP
relaxations and the property of these
relaxations is is that they have very
few constraints and that that will
somehow be important when we have to do
rounding um and examples of these I mean
these are very well studed problem
stochastic napsack stochastic matching
and uh multi- item pricing so I I'll do
all these three um and the third sort of
General uh technique is again very
related to linear programming is
essentially whenever you have a
distribution you can think of sampling
from the distribution right I mean so
what does sampling buy us um so you can
if you take the entire distribution
maybe the the distribution has
exponential size so you can write some
exponential size LP uh but then maybe
this LP can either be solved efficiently
by sampling or you can do something else
using sampling and that makes a running
time polinomial so I'll present examples
which are sort of this multi-stage
optimization uh and basian auctions and
how to solve LPS online I mean these are
just terms for now but I'll describe all
these
problems and the final part of this this
talk will be on scheduling the aspect
that comes up in scheduling is this
aspect of time I mean whenever you think
of a scheduling problem the The crucial
aspect is decisions have to be made over
time right and everything I I'll do in
the first the previous Parts somehow
time is there but we'll never really use
time in any sort of non-trivial way and
but when we do scheduling you have to
use time in some non-trivial way uh I'll
present two techniques for U firstly
I'll show one technique which involves
developing stronger LP relaxations
relaxations with more constraints and
more variables maybe even exponentially
many constraints um and uh the second
technique is just okay if you have a
complicated problem just try greedy
right and I'll show you uh and I'll show
you a beautiful result uh that is from
operations research called the gens
index theorem so that's the overall I
high level picture of the
talk
uh and important disclaimer many of you
work on these problems I'm I can't cover
everything so I'm sorry if what you work
on is not
covered so in the first part I'll show
you I'll Define a very simple decision
problem called the maximum value problem
it's closely related to something called
profit inequalities that Matt is going
to cover uh but I'll present it very
differently okay so in the maximum value
problem think about there's a gambler he
shown n boxes these boxes are closed
um the boxes are in front of the Gambler
uh the what the Gambler knows is that
the Box J has a reward it's drawn from
distribution XJ The Gambler knows XJ but
the box is closed so he doesn't know
what value is there inside it uh and
these distributions are independent so
X1 is independent of X2 which is
independent of x3
okay so this is the Gambler there are
five boxes they are closed um The
Gambler knows these distributions so
what he can do is he can open a box say
he opens box two he sees there's 20
inside now he can now given that he
knows this is 20 he can decide to open
some other box maybe he opens this three
and so on so the constraint on the
problem is that he can open at most K
boxes okay and the final payoff he gets
is the maximum value that he observes in
any of the boxes that he opens okay so
he can adaptively open k boxes uh
depending on what he has opened so far
he can decide which box to open next
right but you only the the constraint is
that he can only open k
boxes
uh and at the end of the process he
looks at the boxes that are open he
picks the maximum value that is his
payoff
okay so as an example suppose you have
three boxes uh Gambler can open two
boxes so this so these are beri so this
is X1 is 50 with probability half zero
with the remaining probability X2 is 60
with probability 1/3 0 with the
remaining probability X3 is
deterministic 25 with probability 1 what
should the G am
do so suppose he opens the first box
okay he observes zero with probability
half okay and now he has to he he has to
open some other box right and whatever
he sees there will be his payoff I mean
this was zero so X3 this guy has payoff
25 this guy if he opens has payoff in
expectation 20 25 beats 20 so he'll open
this box right and he'll get 25 this
determinance
okay now with the other half probability
he would have observed
50 uh if he observes 50 if if this box
already has 50 there's no point in
opening this box because 50 beats 25
right so he'll open this box right if he
opens X2 uh with probability 2/3 he
would have seen zero here in which case
his payoff would be 50 which probability
1/3 he'll see 60 here so his payoff will
be 60 so so this is like an Adaptive
decision tree right so this is one
possible policy for The Gambler open X1
first If You observe zero open X3 If You
observe 50 open X2 now suppose you have
n boxes and you can can open k then just
the description of the
output could have size which is
exponential in in n and
K so that is this is the output of the
problem okay so the output itself need
not be polinomial
and the sort of expected payoff of The
Gambler will be the expectation of this
guy so it's 25 with probability half 50
with probability 1/3 and six sorry no
yeah and 60 with probability 16 so it's
39.67 so now the goal is to find that
decision tree whose expectation is the
largest okay clear and the inputs are
these distributions let's assume they
discrete distributions they have small
support so the input is polinomial
size
good so one thing is can the you can
think of a non-adaptive policies that
are simpler to specify at least the
specification is polinomial size which
is just choose K boxes up front without
even opening them and just open these
boxes and take the maximum value right
just pick a subset K of boxes so now
find the best subset K of boxes to pick
such that their the expected value of
their maximum is as large as possible so
in this case the best solution would be
to pick X1 and X3 up front and open them
in which case with probability half the
payoff is 50 probability half is 25 that
is 37.5 but the but the Adaptive policy
that decides to open the second box
after observing what was in X1 does
strictly
better okay so an Adaptive policy which
can have exponential size could beat a
non-adaptive policy okay so that is
adaptivity versus non
adaptivity uh but there's a subtle point
which is that the 39 37 .5 is not that
much worse than 39.1 67 they are pretty
close in fact I'll show you that they'll
always be
close
Okay what is a benchmark so The
Benchmark we are comparing against is I
told you the value of the optimal
decision tree okay and let's call this
value opt it can have size which is
exponential in K
uh so can our goal is to design a
polinomial Time algorithm that produces
a polinomial size decision tree that
approximates of okay so this is the
approximation algorithm's angle to the
problem
okay is it good I mean if you have
questions just interrupt
me I mean I have background in
approximation algorithms but I I know
many of you have backgrounds in
different areas so if some of the
terminology is not clear and stuff just
let me know okay so you're not
restricting to non-adaptive policies yet
no no no so I'm comparing against yeah
so the I'm comparing against this
optimal decision policy I mean what I
design may be adaptive may not be
adaptive so so later you will tell us
what's the ratio between adaptive and
non adaptive I'll tell you
yes so in fact the just so the outline
for this part will be uh I'll present
approximation algorithms for this
problem I'll first show you suppose you
were just restricting to the space of
nonadaptive policies how do you compute
an approximately good non-adaptive
policy then I'll show you LP relaxation
for the Adaptive policy um and uh then
I'll show you the gap between the
Adaptive and the non-adaptive policy and
since this is a tutorial just ignore the
constant factors I mean sometimes it'll
be large and you might cringe but they
can be improved and that's not the
point and I'll show you in the second
half of the talk I'll show you more
applications of this and I'll show you
other relaxations and so
on okay non-adaptive so suppose we
suppose our Benchmark was not the
optimal adaptive policy but the optimal
non-adaptive policy then can we design
an algorithm that competes against
that so what is a non-adaptive problem
so given a subset s of boxes which you
have not opened if the Gambler just
chooses s and opens them then the payoff
that he'll get will be the expected
value of the max of these
distributions just by definition now you
want to find a set s of size K that
maximizes the expected value of the
max
okay and the basic idea is that okay
this is a set function you have a
cardinality
constraint maybe there's some property
of the set function that will help
us and uh there's a wellknown property
called submodularity for those who
haven't seen it what submodularity means
is simply the it simply means that
diminishing marginal returns okay so
you're given some set function s f okay
take some subset take some set S1 take
another set S2 which is which contains
S1 and take some element T which doesn't
belong to S2 okay then think about
adding T to S1 and look at how much the
function value increases think about
adding T to S2 and think about how much
that function value increases okay the
increase is larger for the smaller set
that's just diminishing returns if you
already have a large set adding one more
element doesn't increase your function
value that
much okay
uh so this is like sort of the discrete
analog of diminishing
returns okay
and the way this is defined I mean this
there are no other constraints on this F
but we'll need two other constraints we
need this function to always be non-
negative we'll also need this function
to be monotone in the sense that if I
have a larger set the function value
also
increases and so non- negativity and
monotonicity are trivial
for this function if I have if I have a
larger set the expected value of the max
is only only going to increase that's
straightforward and this function is
non- negative assuming these XIs are
non-
negative okay good uh so why is
submodularity
interesting if I have to maximize a
submodular function subject to a
cardinality constraint that the size of
this set I pick has to be at most k then
there is a well-known greedy algorithm
for it which is which just does the most
obvious thing which is start with the
empty set okay while the set has it less
than K just pick that element such that
adding that element to S increases the
value the most Okay add that element
continue okay just at every point in
time just add the element which gives
you the largest increase keep going
right
uh there's a classical result due to
nouser W see and Fisher that this greedy
algorithm is not optimal in fact U
maximizing a submodular function subject
to a cardinality constraint is hard to
approximate
uh but it's a 1 minus 1 / e
approximation so it gives you 63% of the
best possible
value
uh and uh this this this number is
actually optimal it's NP hard to get any
it's under some complexity theoretic
assumptions it's hard to improve this um
and there's nothing special about the
cardinality of the set being of size K
the different elements could have
different costs and there could be a
bound on the total cost there could be
other constraints on what set you can
choose uh variants of the greedy
algorithm will work for all of
those and that's a big line of research
in
itself why is this result interesting
the maximum value the function is
actually submodular and the proof is and
and and this is like sort of a very
simple proof and this proof applies more
broadly in the sense that if you want to
if you have a stochastic function you
want to show it as subm modular this
outline will pretty much work right
which is just just look at the Joint
distribution of
these uh look at this joint distribution
right what you'll what what you'll do is
just argue submodularity sample by
sample take some sample from this joint
distribution okay it's a sample of
values for this guy for this guy for
this guy and so on so what is take some
sample of values you could have observed
in the different boxes okay for this
sample uh the value of the function is
simply the
max okay so now these are not
distributions there are just some
numbers I give you n n numbers for any
subset what is the maximum value of
those numbers right and now if you just
take this function right it's very easy
to check that this is subm modular if I
have a larger set adding another value
will not increase the max by that
much
okay uh and but but this function f of s
is simply the expectation overall
samples of this this guy
right the expected value of the max you
can write it as expectation over all
samples you could draw of the max of
that sample right and now this this
submodularity property sorry this
submodularity is like a sort of it's
It's a linear condition so if I just
take expectation right the inequality is
preserved right you can take expectation
of everything and the inequality the
direction of the inequality won't change
right and then that's the whole idea
right I mean that sub marity is
preserved it's just a linear condition
so it's preserved under taking
expectations over all the
samples uh and in fact in this proof I
mean there we didn't use the
independence of these random variables
anywhere I mean you could these could be
correlated the whole thing is still subm
modular in fact if you were to design a
non-adaptive policy it's okay for the
random variables to be
correlated okay
so so if you want to compete against the
optimal non-adaptive policy what we have
shown is that if you just implement the
greedy algorithm which at every point in
time adds that box which increases the
expected value of the max the most
then what you'll get is
63.2% of the value of the optimal
non-adaptive policy okay that is what
the greedy algorithm gives us
and there are lot more things that are
subm modular I mean you could have
payoff instead of from one box you could
have payoff from many boxes it's still
subm modular same idea uh in fact you
could think of minimizing the minimum
value and it turns out the log of that
is also subm
modular and in fact subm modularity if
if I give you a network and I have a
seed I I infect a subset s of nodes and
look at how far the epidemic spreads
right under under many most random
models of how epidemic spread this this
the expected size of the set of nodes
that get infected will be subm modular
is a subm modular function of this what
you
infect uh in fact if I give you a set of
random variables and take any subset of
those random variables and compute its
discrete entropy The Joint entropy that
will be a sub modular function of the
set of random variables you chose it's
not true for continuous entropy but it's
true for discrete
entropy and these things have
applications in the sense that they they
are real world problems that are solved
by by this kind of
stuff um but that's all I have to say
about submodularity and non-adaptive
policies I'll later on show that a
non-adaptive policy actually
approximates optimal adaptive policy
that will come later okay for now we
were just comparing against the optimal
non-adaptive policy
okay and here we'll use linear
program question about ad is it the best
bound I mean it's best Bound for
arbitrary uh sub function I don't know
if it's the best bound so all I could
all we have shown so far is that it's NP
hard to compute the Optima but beyond
that maybe there is it's possible
there's a
pasas
uh
and in the greedy algorithm when there's
dependence you take the
expected it might be hard to compute I
mean Computing the expected Max might be
hard but if you sample I mean you can
maybe if you sample enough from the
distributions you can approximate
it
okay so what is the idea behind linear
programming take the optimal decision
policy we don't know what it is uh it
adaptively opens some K boxes and uh it
obtains payoff from one open box it's
like some such decision tree okay and
we'll Define some variables based on the
behavior of this policy uh and these
variables the important thing about
these variables is that they will only
be confined to one box right I'll Define
variables separately for each box right
because if I put all the boxes together
that will again have exponential
complexity I want I don't want that so
it's a
relaxation so
let uh we can define a variable YJ which
is take this decision
policy it does something and it opens
maybe it opens box J maybe it doesn't
open box J right over its decision tree
what is the probability that box J is
opened call that quantity
YJ that zjv be this thing probability
that the policy opened the box J it
observed value V and that was the final
payoff of of the policy
that among the boxes it opened that was
actually the largest
value
okay so are all distributions now
discrete uh let's assume for now they
are discrete the way at the end you'll
see that it doesn't really matter that
the distributions are discreet I mean
the final policy will be so simple that
it'll even work for continuous
distributions um and in fact the way I'm
writing this LPA it will appear that
this thing is discrete but you can
Define the same thing for continuous
distributions it'll all be fine
okay so just as an example this was our
optimal policy for this example uh the
policy always opens box one so y1 is one
so y1 is the probability that the Box is
open so the policy opens box two with
probability half if it takes this Branch
so Y2 is half similarly Y3 is half so if
I look at the Z variables z1a 50 is the
probability that the policy open box one
observed value 50 and chose that payoff
that would happen happen here so that
would be 1/3 is a probability similarly
z260 is a probability the policy open
box 2 observed 60 and chose that so that
will be 1 16 z325 is a probability open
box 3 was open it payoff was 25 and that
payoff was chosen and that is half okay
and if I give you a big decision tree
it's a bigger computation the point is
we're not going to do this computation
these are just some variables okay okay
good what will we do with these
variables so the basic idea idea is we
want to write an LP that captures the
behavior of this optimal policy and
we'll use these as a variables I mean
these variables are insufficient to
capture the entire structure of the
optimal policy and we don't really want
to do that what we'll end up with I I'll
show you that it'll be a relaxation in a
certain sense and what we'll do is we'll
understand the structure of this
relaxation convert it into a feasible
policy and show that it's an
approximation bound adaptivity Gap and
so
on adaptivity Gap I mean the gap between
the Adaptive and the non adaptive
policies that's the basic
idea okay so for we have to write an LP
so let's look at okay what what
constraint should we
put
so so let Z be the it's it's a random
variable which denotes okay which box
did I obtain payoff from okay and let so
zjv is the probability that the box from
which I obtained the payoff is J and the
value XJ was actually V okay
good so for this event to happen
that I obtained the that I uh I obtained
payoff from J and XJ was V two things
must have happened right the policy must
have opened this box and the and the
value in this box must have been V I
mean a third thing must also happen
which which is that this V was actually
the largest value but let's ignore that
right I
mean for this event to happen at least
these two events must have happened more
stuff must happen but let's ignore that
more stuff
okay here is the important thing right
that these two events are
independent since the the the values in
the boxes are
independent the behavior of the policy
till the point where it opens box J will
be independent of what it's going to see
inside box J because box J has a value
which is independent of everything else
in the
system right so this event that box J is
opened by the policy is independent of
what value is there inside that
box
cool so I can multiply the probabilities
of these two events that's the
important so this this value since is at
most the probability that box J is open
and I observe this value here it must
also be the maximum value that I observe
in all the boxes but it's at most this
right and these two events are
independent so I can just multiply them
out but the probability that the Box J
is open is exactly this value that I
have defined okay and let's call this
this is just the density function of
what is inside box J let's let let me
use the standard notation for density
function let me just call it FJ of V
it's just some notation so there is not
a variable this is something that's
specified as input okay that's the
density
function I don't want to keep writing
this
quantity okay good so zjv won't be equal
to this guy because what we are not
encoding here is that
V was actually the largest value that
the policy
observed this is sort of a
relaxation good that gives us one
constraint is it
clear this is this constraint okay what
is the other constraint
right
uh so what is djv right zjv is the
probability that the payoff was obtained
from box J and there and the value that
is obtained is V but the policy can only
get payoff from one
box and one value of that box right so
which means that the by linearity of
expectation all these ZJ vs must sum to
one right because a policy always
regardless of what decision path it
takes it's only choosing one box and one
value right so these must sum to
one okay so what we are essentially
encoding this is like an expected value
constraint what we are saying is that
the expected number of boxes from which
the payoff is obtained is
one we not we are not encoding that on
every decision path the payoff is one on
only one box is chosen if it's true for
any every decision path it's also true
in expectation and the expectation is
what we are capturing
here in the same way the policy opens at
most K boxes on any decision path so
that must be true in
expectation look at the what is the
expected number of boxes that it opens
the probability that J is opened is YJ
if I sum this that'll be the expected
number of boxes the policy opens that
must be at most K because on any
decision path the policy opens at most K
boxes whatever is true on any decision
path is also true in expectation that's
all we are
saying
okay and in this this number is a
probability and if I encode this is a
prob this lies between 0 and one it also
encodes this Li between 0 and one
because I'm multiplying it by a
fraction that's it and now what do you
want to do we want a policy with the
largest payoff so the payoff of any
policy is just by again by linearity of
expectation if it opened box J Saw V and
chose that value the payoff would be V
so I just multiply that and summ it over
all possible J's and
V's so I want to maximize this guy
subject to all these
constraints so now I have an I have a
linear
program it has reasonable number of
variables and constraints there's the
the number of JS is polinomial the
number of JS is n number of values per J
is small let's assume that and there
only two constraints really here that's
it so you don't need positivity for
z uh yeah Z needs to be positive Z will
be positive because I'm maximizing
something here
so yeah I've written papers where I've
dropped constraints like this and the
reviewers point it out
and but yeah I should have written all
those
constraints
okay so here is a simple
example uh suppose I have two boxes
there's two with probability half zero
with probability half this box is 1
0 suppose k equals 2 so I can open both
the boxes right in which case any LP
solution is just going to set the why
the the probability of opening this box
to one the probability of opening this
box to one so those constraints are
trivial right but still this LP does
something weird what will the lp do so
what is this LP right so so let's call
this guy Za A2 which is like the
pro so this is box a has value two what
do I do with it this box B has value one
what do I do with it right so LP says
that okay the probability that I the
expected number of boxes I choose is one
that is this constraint now za2 is at
most the probability that this guy was
had value two which is half similarly
zb1 is the probabil at most the
probability that this guy has value one
which is half right I'm opening these
boxes deterministically I'm opening
these boxes with probability one so this
would have been multiplied by ya a but y
is one okay so I'm just why I'm dropping
all the Y ybs so this is just an LP on
the Z's there's some LP what is its
optimal
solution optimal solution sets this guy
to half this guy to half that's the best
it can do but what does that mean right
if this if za2 is half that means if
whenever I observe two I must have
chosen the
box right only then can this value
become half right and similarly zb1
being half means that whenever I see one
I choose this
box okay that's what the lp is telling
us to do open both the boxes whenever
you see two here choose this whenever
you see one here choose this and the
value you'll get is
1.5 but it's not
feasible right because the policy is
constrained to any feasible policy is
always constrained to choosing only one
box right and there is a small
probability with which this box will
have two and this box will have value
one in fact with probability 1/4 this
guy will be two and this guy will be one
in which case I any feasible policy
can't choose both these boxes but the lp
doesn't care about that constrained
there's nothing that says that in some
decision path you can't choose two
boxes all it is capturing is something
in
expectation in fact the optimal decision
policy would be that if you see two here
choose it otherwise if you see one here
choose it and that will have value 1.25
that'll correspond to setting this guy
to half and this guy to 1/4
but the lp doesn't the lp has too few
constraints to capture
that so it doesn't capture constraints
across boxes what happens if both these
boxes have this value but that would
that would be exponential
complexity y I was probability to choose
the Box open the box Z is the
probability of choosing the
Box Y is one in since K is two I can
open both the boxes I set Y is to one so
that's why I'm not multiplying by y here
the Y is just assumed to
be but even then even in that extremely
simple case right the lp is
not the lp is still not giving us the
optimal policy it's giving us a
relaxation of the optimal
policy okay so what do we
do so what do we do with this LP
solution we'll convert it into a
feasible policy and bound the payoff and
we'll bound its payoff in terms of the
lp Optimum right so the lp Optimum is
some upper bound it ignores a lot of
constraint so it gives us a reward which
could be larger than what any feasible
policy could get uh what we'll but what
we'll do is we'll take this LP Optimum
and convert it into a feasible policy
and show that we don't lose that much in
the
reward so what do the lp what does the
lp give us right I mean the lp didn't
give us the optimal policy so what did
it give us right so if you what the what
the lp has are variables for every box
right so just focus on some box J right
LP has a variable YJ and it has variable
ZJ vs okay so what this is saying is
open box J with probability YJ if you
see value V then take this payoff with
probability ZJ ided by YJ * fjv so this
is the this sort of this is the
conditional probability right so if you
uncondition it the probability that you
will open observe and choose will be
exactly as
EAS
so so let's call this a single box
policy which is essentially saying if I
focus on box
J what is a policy for this box you open
the box with some probability You
observe a value inside If You observe
value V you'll choose the box with some
probability okay so that gives us a
class of policies for one box what to do
with this
box so just to simplify notation if I
give you some policy for this box right
which has those which you can specify in
this form okay let call let's let opj be
the probability that the policy opens
this box cpj is the probability that you
choose the payoff of this box which is
this guy and rpj is the expected reward
you get from this choice right which is
this guy now you can write the lp in
terms of the simpler notation what is
the lp telling us the lp is essentially
telling us find one policy for each box
one feasible policy for each box which
opens the box with some probability if
you see something choose it with some
probability
right and there only two constraints
that if I take all these policies and
put them together the expected number of
choices made is at most one and the
expected number of boxes opened is at
most K subject to these two constraints
I want to maximize my expected
result it's not capturing any other
correlation or joint actions between
these boxes for every box find me one
policy such that if I just put them
together these two constraints are
satisfied so this size is the function
of the maximum value of each of the
distribution like um your um one of the
const is overall B so it is um the size
of the L is a function of yeah yeah yeah
yeah so
um if you wait around a bit I'll show
you that the the size of the
distribution doesn't really matter as
long as you can compute some some simple
quantities for this distribution it'll
all be okay right you don't really in
fact you don't really need to solve this
LP the final algorithm won't even need
to solve this LP this LP is more for
Thought purposes okay okay
good oh sorry yeah um for again maybe if
you open a single box and if you see two
different values of take not only one so
how even if you see 1,000 if you see 9
900 you still take both so how it is
captured in this thing no for from every
box you only see one
value if I open if I open the box I see
one value from that distribution so
there's some value inside the box but
there are not two a box cannot have two
values inside it may have I mean depends
on depends on what you see I mean it's
for
distribution no no no I the way I set up
the problem the box has some value
inside it it has one value inside it uh
what you know UPF front is the
distribution of that
value so the Box cannot have two values
inside
it so for the second constraint and no
actually for the first and second
constraint why is it um smaller or equal
but not strictly equal to 1 and K
actually it will be strictly equal I
want to take the Dual lers as why I
wrote it this way but if you solve it
it'll set it to
equal
okay
so what does LP give us so LP gives us
one policy for each box it's call it a
single box policy that tells us what to
do with this box it has only two
constraints that the expected number of
choices made by all these policies is
one the expected number of openings done
by all these policies is K and we know
that since this LP is a
relaxation the reward the sum of the
rewards is at least the value of the
optimal policy this much we know right
but the point is that if I just put
these policies together it's not
feasible right I mean it could be that
many of these policies simultaneously
decide to choose their boxes weird stuff
can
happen Okay so we want to convert this
guy into a feasible policy so suppose we
could solve this LP let's convert it
into a feasible policy I'll show later
that it doesn't you don't even need to
solve this LP okay but suppose you
solved this LP you got this stuff let's
convert it into a feasible policy so
just this first step is just I'll give
you a very simple algorithm just order
the boxes arbitrarily 1 2 3 4 somehow
okay and consider the boxes in this
order when suppose the policy encounters
box J then with probability 34 just skip
this box with probability 1/4 this is
where I'm sort of keep in mind to ignore
my constants right um with probability
1/4 execute what the lp is telling you
to do which is this policy
PJ so what does the PJ do right I mean
it with some probability decides to open
this box and if it opened and observing
some value it decides to take its
payoff if the policy decides to take the
payoff then take this payoff stop
because you can't take any more
payoffs okay else move to the next box
again do this
business if you have already opened K
boxes then
stop now this policy is feasible because
you're never going to open more than K
boxes and you're never going to choose
the payoff from more than one box
there's a very simple way of converting
what the lp gives you into something
that is
feasible now what we want to argue is
that this is
okay that this gives you some
approximation this guy
opt the reward that this whole thing
gives you is at least some factor of
opt EXC why would you open K boxes every
time if it's just why would you stop
before opening K
boxes you would you won't stop uh
because you could have the the the
policy PJ that you execute could have
take chosen the payoff of yeah I mean
yeah you could go till you open k boxes
um the for the I'm going to it doesn't
improve the analysis so what I'm going
to
analyze you're right I mean this is like
somewhat dumb in fact there are better
ways of doing stuff yeah we I don't mind
ignoring the three quarters but could
you just tell us sort of where it it'll
come I'll tell you where it comes I'm
going to analyze this thing yeah so when
you reach K you stop no payoff there
could be no payoff I mean you could have
opened boxes and you could have seen
zeros everywhere or you just choose
whatever the max you observed so far but
for the way I describe this algorithm
this this is exactly what I'm going to
analyze if you implement it you can
implement it in a much better way than
what is described
here in fact there
are there is no reason to order the
boxes arbitrarily you can order them
more cleverly than
arbitrarily there's there a whole bunch
of I mean this analysis is very
slack
okay so let's define some random
variables for the execution of this
policy so let OJ be a random variable
which is one if box J is opened let CJ
equals 1 if if the final payoff that is
chosen by the policy is from box J so
the policy reaches a sum box I if two
things hold so these are both 01
variables so the number of so all this
is saying is how many boxes were chosen
before J so if this value is zero then
the polic that means nothing was chosen
till the till the policy reaches high
this is the number of boxes that are
open before I if less than K boxes are
open then the policy can still continue
so the policy reaches box ey it didn't
stop if this quantity the number of
boxes open so far is less than one and
the number of sorry number of boxes open
so far is less than K and the number of
boxes chosen so far is less than one
right these are all 01 random variables
is a complicated way of just saying that
thisy this guy must be zero and this guy
must be at most K minus one okay and
what we'll do is lower bound this
probability what we'll show is that the
policy reaches box side with
sufficiently large probability for every
box
and here is where we'll use just use
Markov inequality so the probability
that this this a random variable
probability is less than one is at least
one minus the expected value of this
random variable probability this random
variable is less than K is at least one
minus the expected value of this random
variable divided by K this is just this
is called marov
inequality I'm not going to prove this I
mean standard okay okay so now what we
need to do is calculate this guy and
this guy right so the probability that
the the policy reaches box ey is the
probability of both these events
happening which is at least 1 minus this
guy by Marco's inequality just by Union
bounds okay so we need to calculate this
guy and this guy what is expected so
what is the expected value of CJ right
this is the probability the policy
chooses something from box this is the
expected value of CJ given that box J is
not skipped I mean you reach box J you
could skip it if so you have to not skip
it you have to actually go inside uh
time the probability that the box box is
not skipped right so this is
just calculation uh and probability the
box is not skipped is 1/4 it's
probability 34 I'm just skipping the Box
condition of not skipping it I'm going
to execute this policy and that that
chooses the box with probability cpj so
this is the LP value okay condition I'm
not skipping it I'm just going to
execute the lp so LP tells me to choose
the box with this probability so this
guy this random variable is at most this
guy it's clear right I mean probability
1/4 I'm not skipping in fact the
probability is going to be less than 1/4
because I may not even reach this box
right and similarly the probability that
the Box J is open is the probability
that it it's open given that it is not
skipped times the probability it is not
skipped probability is not skipped is
1/4 condition on not skipping it the lp
tells you to open with this probability
so it's this guy it it's going to be
even less than that because you may not
even reach this box but whatever it's an
upper BX that's all we
want and this is where the skipping and
the 1/4 is coming
in
yeah so now just plug those values in
this is the probability the policy
reaches box ey this is markov's
inequality just plug those numbers in
here right so you have this 1/4 because
of the skipping business times this guy
now the lp tells you that the sum of all
these values is at most one the lp tells
you the sum of all these values is at
most K so the lp is telling you that all
this guy is at most
two so LPS so just plug that in here
you'll tell you the probability that the
policy reaches any box ey is at least
half okay all we have used is marov
inequality that's it I me you just use
the lp constraints in saying that this
guy is at most one and this guy is at
most
K okay and this 1/4 is just to make sure
this thing works out it to skip with
sufficient probability to make this guy
large so if you had three constraints
you would put down a six out there or
something like that
yeah blows up in the number of
constraints
okay so now what we do is say that okay
what is the reward of this policy by
linearity of expectation the reward of
this policy is the sum of the expected
rewards it gets from each box okay when
will it get a reward from a box it has
to
reach the Box not skip it and do
something with the box right so the
probability that the box is reached is
half at least a half times the expected
reward from this guy so it's half times
the probability that the box is not
skipped and given that both of these
things have happened it's going to do
something with the Box it'll do what the
lp tells it to
do so it's at least half * 1/4th times
whatever the lp is telling it so it's
going to be RPI /8 so from box I from
from any box eye the expected reward the
policy gets is at least what the lp gets
divided by
cool and for this we crucially needed
that like every box is reached with
sufficiently large probability and that
needs us to skip boxes with sufficiently
large probability so it's these are the
best constants you can plug in for to
make this work yeah so I also so this is
also saying that you get eight
approximation for take it or leave it
off is not just maximum of K
open yeah maximum of even for take it or
leave it in fact the eight is not tight
I mean you can get two
this okay so since I only have five
seven more minutes so this this so just
after this point you just use linearity
of expectation the from every box I'm
getting 1/8 of what the lp gets by
linearity of expectation the total
reward of my policy is at least 1/8 of
the LP value okay gives you an eight
approximation the constant is bad you
can improve it to two
whatever okay but this policy is like
sort of adaptive right I mean it uh it's
not really but but let's just show okay
what is an
adapt to show an adaptivity Gap right I
mean what we'll do is we'll look at this
LP and say okay look let's not solve the
lp let's see if this LP has some very
simple
structure okay let's look at the lp
again is
blah uh there are two constraints I
don't like two constraints let's write
it as one constraint let's just add the
two
constraints okay this is just saying I
just divided this second constraint by K
added it up okay this is an even weaker
LP right I don't like this number
two so let's since this an LP I can just
scale everything down by a factor of two
it loses some two in my
objective now one one is
nice again this is all very loose there
are better ways to do these
things uh okay so this is a very this is
a very weak LP this value is at least
opt over two because I've scaled stuff
down by a factor of two okay good I have
only one constraint now uh that connects
the different JS together everything
else is within a j right I have one
constraint the nice thing about one
constraint is I can take the
lran so let's define some dual variable
W here and let's put that in the
objective so this is what I'll get what
is this guy I'm maximizing so I'm
maximizing something which is a sum over
J but the constraints are only for each
J separately there's nothing that
couples the J together in the
constraints okay so now if you want to
solve this you just solve separately for
each J there's nothing connecting the J
together so if I fix if I focus on a
particular J what is it solving it's
solving it's maximizing this quantity
subject to PJ being feasible but what is
this quantity right if I look at it it's
reward if I open the box I'm paying W
over
K if I choosing the re if I'm choosing
the reward I'm I'm paying
W okay so there maximizing reward Minus
cost the cost for opening is W over K
cost for choosing is w i want to find
that policy for this particular box that
maximizes reward Minus
cost and this policy has a very simple
structure now it's like one
box what can I do right I can either
open the box or not open the box there's
no reason to do stuff probabilistically
right so just take the better of two
options suppose I don't open the box
everything is zero I gained nothing I
lost nothing zero open the box I paid W
over k for opening if my reward is
bigger than W I might as well take that
reward because I'll I'll obtain the
reward and pay W so that's a positive
number so the net value would be the
expected reward minus all this cost it's
a very simple policy right I mean it'll
in fact say that there there'll be
there's this threshold W okay uh open
the box if the reward is more than W
choose it that is one the other option
is to just not do anything take the
better of these two
solutions so here is a case where if you
take the Dual take the lran and it's
telling you it's giving you a very
simple policy so why is the lagrangian
useful roughly speaking because of
strong Duality right the the the
solution to the original LP corresponds
to choosing a w such that this quantity
is equal to one as the as I increase
this penalty or this cost right W then
it's less and less likely the policy
will even open a box or choose something
because the cost is too high right so
there'll be some point where as I
increase W there will be some point
where this quantity the expected cost
Cost Plus expected cost becomes equal to
one at that point by strong Duality the
the value of the lran must be equal to
the LP value which is off
to so you can solve the lp by
essentially doing a binary search over W
right for every W you just compute these
policies for each box which have a very
simple structure and now just do a
binary search of w to find that w at
which this constraint is
satisfied this roughly speaking there
are some technicalities there could be
two
W's for those who are familiar with this
technique this doesn't exactly work but
roughly speaking this is the
idea okay so now what it shows the moral
of the story is that this LP Optimum has
a very simple structure right it is it
has some threshold W okay and uh for
that W it computes the single box
policies which either doesn't open the
box or if it opens the box it chooses it
if the reward is more than w
right the important thing is that the
decision to open the box is
deterministic the policy either doesn't
open the box or opens the box but I have
this LP constraint which says that the
number of boxes open can be at most K
right which means that if I take this LP
Optimum solution it must have opened at
most K boxes this the number of JS for
which it would have set this for which
the policy would open the boxes at
mostly I mean that's why I scaled it
down by a factor I mean so if you look
at this constraint right right I'm
saying this OJ is like a deterministic
value either opens the box or doesn't
open the box this guy is one so this OJ
must be at most K some of the OJs must
be at
most so the lp Optimum is is telling you
okay here are K boxes at most K boxes
and their yjs are
one now what I do is suppose I just open
all those
boxes okay what I'm the value I get must
be at least what rounding this LP will
get us the rounding is only worse right
but the rounding is getting us it lost a
factor of eight and I lose another
factor of two because I scale down by
factor of two so it's factor of 16
off but if I open all these boxes I have
a non-adaptive policy I just solve this
LP for this value of I solve the lran
from this value of w it's telling me
okay here are K boxes for which YJ is
one right and I just go ahead and open
those K boxes it's a non-adaptive policy
and choose the max right uh if I do this
complicated LP rounding it is only worse
right which means that this non-adaptive
policy must have had value at least op
over 16 which means adaptivity Gap is 16
is a horrible constant you can improve
it to three U but is the idea clear that
if you if once you take the Dual right I
mean this dual has such a simple
structure and by strong Duality that
will tell you that the original LP also
had very simple structure you don't
really need to solve the lp you just
have this
threshold and just decide okay for each
box should I open not open
right and just do binary search over the
threshold till it satisfies the lp
constraint that's it that doesn't need
you to write this complicated LP for
every threshold I can easily compute
what the expected value of the policy
is and so it gives you a policy with
very simple structure and once you have
this policy you can see that okay the
the decision to open every box is
deterministic there's no YJ is not a
fraction and once you have that it's
what you have is a non-adaptive policy
that's
it and this kind of idea I'll show you
again in the next second half of the
talk where The Duality is powerful in
stochastic optimization for this reason
that it once you have the Dual you can
reason more about
structure yeah that is an
explanation sometimes the way we do
approximation algorithms this could be
your question is very valid but yeah it
is an
exclamation yeah so you said that this
doesn't exactly work why is that um for
the simple reason that uh uh there may
be no setting of w for which this guy is
exactly won I mean maybe for some value
it's less than one and make W slightly
larger and becomes greater than one so
the lp Optimum would correspond to like
two very close by W's it's a convex
combination of two very close by
W's uh and the lagrangian for those but
that's a technicality I don't want to
dwell too much on it in fact if you want
to show an adaptivity Gap you don't go
this this route in fact there's a very
different setting of dual variable that
directly gives you
three but the basic idea is this that
the lran has very simple
structure so where does the uh
submodular solution fall with respect
this so this shows that if I compute the
optimal um so suppose I I do the greedy
algorithm right that is 1- 1 over e
against the best non-adaptive solution
but the best non-adaptive solution is
only factor three off from the best
adaptive solution so overall it's three
* e over e minus
one in fact what you can show is that
it's this this whole LP business
actually gives you the non-adaptive
solution directly you don't need to
actually do greedy you do this threshold
business and search what you get is a
non-adaptive
solution yeah returning to a question
before if you're if you are are but it's
supposed to take the last one
so then doesn't work I mean that's
that's Matt
talk that's roughly speaking Matt stock
that's the profit inequality setting in
fact similar thing will work there as
well you have lower bound on the gap
between adaptive and non
adaptive and I know it's at most three
no I don't have a lower bound
on it'll be at least some
constant uh but uh I I don't have a
tight
result so in the previous algorithm
since you know the distribution how
would you uh set the boxes order the
boxes uh you would order it in you just
do napsack right I mean you order it in
decreasing order of reward divided by
the cost so say in fact if you look at
it this way right I mean it just do
reward divided by the cost expected
reward divided by the expected
choose that ordering and you can do
something better you'll get you won't
get two you'll get four I think because
you have two
constraints since the distribution is
fixed in the beginning is it
possible Gap is arbitr close to one even
approximation
Gaper can be some constant as you said
no no no the adaptivity Gap there are
stochastic optimization problems I mean
even if the distributions are fixed the
non-adaptive policy could be much worse
than the Adaptive policy so
it's um there you can easily construct
problems where the adaptivity Gap is bad
for this it'll I think be at least a
constant so Comm the example you gave at
the beginning just the three B yeah yeah
that that had 3.9 versus 3.7 3.9 39
versus 37.5 that was yeah it will be it
can be bad even with fixed
distributions um do you have examples in
this max value kind of problem where
actually describing the optimal strategy
requires exponential in
K description size so it it may be that
they all have six sync descriptions open
questions that that that's that's
a I I don't have proofs Beyond NP
hardness for any of these things I mean
showing that so there are if if you if
you have you can come up with sort of
contrived Markov decision processes
which are like P space complete right
what you're saying is I mean is this
problem P space complete essentially
right uh but for these sort of natural
decision problems I mean even for I'll
show you in the next talk like even for
beian auctions some or beian pricings
showing its NP hard itself is like a
paper in itself and for these I don't
know if I mean for the non-adaptive
policy I have an NP hardness proof but
uh I don't have anything more than that
so that's a very interesting open
question the the more simple you make
the problem the harder it is to show
these kind of
results so what you might have already
answered so what's the best adaptive
policy constraint that you know for this
problem for adaptive I think three is
the best that I so the the
this in fact the adaptivity Gap and the
approximation both three is the
best yeah even like adaptivity does
not no that's another interesting open
question okay let's thank Comm and take
questions I